um hey uh so you're a big sneaker guy
yeah give me your top five like sneakers
silhouettes of all time Silhouettes not
even like specifically yeah so I'm gonna
go uh Jordan eights Jordan Fives Jordan
Ones for sure you know I'm the
separation of Jordan Miz and Jordan
highs I've been going by that for the
longest
um Air Force ones of course and for that
last spot
it's kind of tough
but I'ma say
I really love the Air Raids okay I
really love the air right so you're
gonna put the Jordan eights number one
Jordan yeah Aquas bro oh man aqua's
black and chrome eights [__] hate h
what are we talking about bro that's the
hardest shoe ever bro nah give me the
cement threes symmetries is tough too
you know what I'm saying
I love sixes but you know so you're like
an eight you're like eights yeah like
eights that's my shoe you're like a
unicorn yeah for real that's that's my
shoe I feel like my shoes I feel like I
don't I don't own a pair of eights I
don't even the aqua eights I'm just I'm
straight they're just like the straps
and so you gotta it's just a certain way
you gotta wear them you get drippy in
them joints though I'm sure you can yeah
for sure I don't think I'm interested in
getting drippings of jordanates hey man
teachers on man and the sixes I feel
like six is sit you said there's I feel
like anytime sixes drop recently they're
sitting everywhere yeah you know I feel
that way too I think they just dropped
like some more gray ones the wolf gray
ones are everywhere yeah they're
everywhere for a fact they gotta bring
back some of those classic colors man
those Jordan fours those SBS about to
drop Crazy Fire crazy I'm hoping I can
get my hands on them but I'll never have
no luck on Nike app so the Nike app is
trash yeah are those on the Nike app
because they're SB I don't know if
they're I think they might drop on the
Nike app yeah there was a store that we
used to go to man back in the day um it
was over on Elmwood and buffalo and uh
it was called Sunday I believe Sunday
skate shop and they would get like those
collabs like I got a pair of ones from
there back in the day man it's it's
tough to get your hands on the SB
collides when they do them if someone
goes to Buffalo where do they get
buffalo wings from Buffalo wings from
you gotta go to um I love Kelly Corner
Wings I've been there yeah Kelly Corner
that place is interesting yeah it's
different and it got a different type of
like hot wing too because it's not like
a sauce yeah we're just some old lady
there smoking and serving drinks yeah
with the glasses she was just a
one-person staff yeah she's been in
there thugging for a long time because
[__] the first time I went there was
maybe five six years ago I was like I
hope she sweats in our wings because I
feel like that would be the special
ingredient for real from Kelly's corner
for real so go to Kelly's corner
get you a Guinness it's definitely like
a bar yeah yeah it's a bar yeah um uh
listen for you like talk about
for like your if you know if you've been
planning this album for two years you
came up with the title during the
pandemic
do you feel any pressure are you nervous
at all like how people are going to
receive receive something that you've
put so much into no I'm not nervous at
all because you know I put my I put my
life into it right you know what I mean
it's authentic it's it's like it's one
of those projects where when you walk
away from it like I said you just get a
real sense of who the artist is and
every song like me as an artist period
I've never I've never wanted to be put
into a box and so there's a lot of
different flows a lot of different
sounds on there different beats and so
it's it's got something for everybody
you know what I mean like when I say
I'll be joking with my man Chad all the
time and I say yo we go on Billboard
number one and I always like I'm I'm
serious because you know what I mean I
feel like the project just speaks to
everybody it's a song on the album that
everyone can like but as a as a whole
like as a body of work it's just a
beautiful like piece of work like I
can't really say too much else about it
and it's me you know what I mean so if
you [__] with Jay skis you know what I
mean like you'll appreciate it you'll
love it and if not if you don't even
know who Jay skis is it's a song on
there that's gonna reel you in you know
what I'm saying